check out the story we got from the
hollywood reporter netflix fires
employee for leaking confidential
information on chapelle special the
employee leaked financial data to
bloomberg which reported in october 13
our october 13th article that netflix
spent 24.1 million dollars on dave
chappelle's the closer whoo
not only is dave chappelle smacking down
wokeness and just speaking his mind he's
getting paid that kind of money to do it
nice wow that was half of what he walked
away uh from comedy central for so he's
he's made it back i'm guessing and good
for dave yeah well he also said he's not
going to speak about this again he says
it's over i'm not going to be doing um
specials i'm done
i got to say watching the special it
feels like they got him dave chappelle
was like um i can't do this anymore he
said i'm not going to make these jokes
anymore because if they don't get it i
don't know i can't do it dave chappelle
gave him
that's too bad because he's a cultural
force and he can change people's minds
he did it before he walked away from the
chappelle show just went to africa for a
while
he's checked out he does what he wants
yeah i think i think it was because um i
think his story was that when he did the
chappelle show he did a sketch that was
critical of racism but the people like
he talked to someone who didn't know
that's what it was and it kind of got
mad that he was like is that what you
think i'm trying to say i remember
reading a story about that i don't know
maybe it's been a long time i'm getting
the story wrong but something like that
here's where i think it's really crazy
netflix says
we are on the right side of history in
rao on internal message board over the
comedian's jokes that that to me is is
the crazy crazy thing he says quote we
let go a spokesperson said we let go of
an employee for sharing confidential
commercially sensitive information
outside the company we understand this
employee may have been motivated by
disappointment and hurt with netflix but
maintaining a culture of trust and
transparency is core to our company the
long time employee was fired because
they leaked that information but to say
that they're on the right side of
history i do believe that our commitment
to artistic expression and pleasing our
members is the right long-term choice
for netflix and that we are on the right
side but only time will tell that's what
he said apparently what they said to the
new york times
this is what you get when you uh let
when you let this stuff go on for too
long and now it's biting them in the ass
so good uh and that part of it i'm i'm
extremely happy about to see them suffer
these consequences yeah i mean that
being said maybe not supporting them is
still the right move maybe
oh i don't support centralized um
entertainment networks like this i think
you need a decentralized network that's
going to have propagate the art because
anytime you have a gatekeeper you're
going to have people saying yes or no
and that's the problem it's not that
they said no it's saying giving someone
the ability to say yes or no and get
super rich off it well on that note
there are a lot of different options
that you have you can let the free
market decide where you're going to
spend your entertainment dollars i use
hulu that's my choice i don't know if
you completely agree with them or
whatever but you can use disney plus you
can use hulu you can use like directv
and amazon awful
they're all so oh i know they're all bad
in different ways hulu did that tweet
where they were like remember a couple
years ago don't wear halloween costumes
that are insensitive and i'm like why is
why why is my
online streaming platform telling you
what to wear because you get a central
authority that builds up millions
billions of followers and then they sell
the company to some idiot that gets to
get the twitter account and of 40
million people and can tell you to do
stupid stuff and now most of these
platforms are filled with ads you're
paying a premium just for a specific uh
channel and now amazon hulu all of them
are like paramount they're all playing
ads before you get to watch the content
that you paid for like it's just another
slap in the face of to the consumer
and that's probably why they're not
doing that well and they're going to all
have to yeah they're one of them's
probably going to get bought up by
like paramount it might be for sale by
apple but sometimes and they're way too
late in the ad game but the reason
you know i i think netflix is way too
powerful uh and they're a billion dollar
corporation that does make way you know
they were uh
this is a rumor okay but they were
thinking about uh going into content
creation like youtube they thought about
it seriously three years ago
ditched out of it
yeah they it was just too they were too
far behind right uh but their
infrastructure i had i had a good friend
who worked on work with them in the
early days that infrastructure that they
worked on that for years so they are
light years ahead of any other streaming
service for a long time uh they have
patents on certain menus that's why
you're on disney plus you're on
paramount plus you're like why is this
menu set well they own half of it half
most of the menus and stuff they own the
patents on that so they can't go
remember what wasn't amazon gonna do a
youtube thing few years back remember
that yeah well they're doing some kind
of live streaming thing now which is
weird no on amazon on the website
they're doing like here watch this live
stream which is like usually someone
trying to you know sell products that's
pretty weird
amazon live is that what that is yeah is
this the right side of history is the
question i don't think so centralized
authorities are not we're not going to
look back on having a gatekeeper as as
the right side it's going to i guess i
looked at it like freedom of expression
not centralized authority so i suspect
what's happening with netflix is that
they're looking at twitter and they're
looking at their marketing data and
they're like okay twitter is really not
real life and what's going to be best
for us is actually having diverse
viewpoints and diverse opinions whether
everyone agrees with stuff like cuties
or whether everyone agrees with stuff
like dave chappelle or not which i think
is probably smart and will do them well
in the long term you know the challenges
this is where our culture's at
i mean you've got dave chappelle the
closer on netflix it's a point of
conversation people people group around
it and that means people have to get a
subscription to be able to watch it or
you know borrow a friend but for the
most part it means more subscriptions
and that's exactly what netflix wants
then they'll probably just keep doing
the same controversial stuff back and
forth generate more controversy which is
good for their business no matter what
happens
i agree i
i want i like dave chappelle i'm gonna
side with dave chappelle and not netflix
and i think the only reason
uh netflix is supporting dave chappelle
is because they gave him 24 million
dollars and it's just they're weighing
out like what what you know because if
they if they
paul that's special oh yeah uh that that
that they're just weighing what the
backlash is going to be what's going to
be worse and they're are they publicly
they're publicly traded too aren't they
yes yeah imagine explaining to the to
your shareholders why we dumped 24
million dollars in dave chappelle only
to pull it within like a week or
something or it's been a little bit
longer than that but still
uh yeah i i
having a thousand if i think if a
thousand employees do walk out that
might make a difference i mean there's a
lot of people there i don't know if that
is actually going to happen i mean
that's something i mean i mean who's
saying that like where's the claim
coming from there's going to be a
thousand people coming out on protests i
mean
maybe insiders i mean yeah that just
seems extremely optimistic you could you
could never ask protesters how many
people are out of protest because
they're they're always going to uh
exaggerate the number and it's just
ridiculous to think that's going to
happen but but have any of these people
watch the show because i think if they
do they would get a sense of
understanding and it's not about that
though i know of course it's not you go
to these people and you're like here's
the video clip of what he actually said
and they're going to be like you're a
bigot yeah it's like okay netflix net
worth is 280 billion whoa really as of
october 14 yeah wow whoa look how that
is shot up in the last year
people got to watch something
everybody's like 100. 200. i guess
here's the question you know uh
do you think that we're going to see
more companies trying to embrace
anti-woke stuff because look at what
bill maher said bill maher said for the
first time he's playing to a mixed
audience he said people are hungry for
critiques of the woke left
it's like right to the party bill but i
get it uh yeah
he's way late to that party people are
starving for stuff like that but i don't
think they're going to go to broadcast
entertainment for it i think they're
finding it right here and right on
youtube with other people
and i think they are way late i would
like to see the establishment
uh turn it around i just have very
little faith they they need a lot of
they need a lot of failures
uh which they haven't had they've been
able to either hide them or you know who
knows what's true anymore like they're
starting to hide
uh tv failures now they're starting you
know they're they're not giving they
don't have to give out numbers for
streaming services you know you know
what i don't believe
i don't believe anyone liked kimmy
schmidt
i don't either i do you watch it i
watched it you liked it i liked it lies
i'm a i'm a i'm such a big fan of 30
rock i will tell you why i like kimmy
schmidt because she was trapped
underground in a bunker and as someone
who was homeschooled and isolated from
the rest of the world for my entire
upbringing that really resonated with me
so i don't know if that's that one that
made the jokes funny i guess oh i liked
it so this is cute
look i watch you know i just binged 30
rock again because i periodically will
watch 30 rock because it's amazing and i
just laugh non-stop it's brutally
hilarious
and then i'm like i finished it and i
was like okay i'm going to watch kimmy
schmidt i tried to watch it before i got
to watch it because it's the it's it's
tina fey
very similar style of humor and then i'm
two episodes in with my eyes just like
half closed like not a single left maybe
a chuckle like
and then i was like how i look at the i
look at the ratings on rotten tomatoes
and it's like award-winning number one
and i'm like dude
i understand how the media lies because
i pay attention to politics i'm looking
at these shows and i'm like i really
don't believe people are
that into this show and it only got i
think four seasons which says to me it
was doing bad people didn't like it the
media lies try and make money and then
ultimately they cancel it because people
weren't watching that's my opinion i
don't know jack murphy said he liked it
maybe that's just me then i don't think
you're ever going to get truly anti-woke
sustainable anti-woke or or like edgy
stuff out of corporate media ever i mean
you already have broadcast things you
can't say the f word you can't talk
about this i can't joke about this on
this show so it's really not ant it's
not like a comedy show where i i can be
free
there's there's always corporations can
be sold to some idiot so you need a
decentralized
way for for the comedy to thrive i think
there there are always limits right
people need to understand this too this
is what gets lost in the free speech
debate you can't go on tucker carlson's
show and say a lot of things they'd ban
you i think jesse kelly was was he the
one who got well it's not michael
nolan's it's not tucker it's cnn or it's
it's fox yeah if you go on tucker's show
with him with that owns the network and
has like owns the isp he could let you
do whatever you want but it's it's about
um look the reason we don't swear on
this show is not because youtube's gonna
ban us for doing it tons of people swear
it's because we've gotten emails from
people being like hey my kids are with
me when the show's on you know would you
guys mind giving the swears down and i'm
like we don't lose anything by not
swearing and there are kids who are
watching and we really want younger
people to like hear the message and be
with their parents i'm like that makes
sense to me so we ask people like you
know don't swear but if you do we're not
going to cry cultural choice yeah so
like the same thing is true for a lot of
shows that will be like hey you know we
have our limits on what we're willing
but like in 2008 you could swear and it
was almost like the kids loved it and
that was when larry and sergey own the
company and then they sold it i'm not
talking about youtube i'm talking about
uh we got in we got an email we get
emails periodically um from back when we
used to swear a lot more and they'd be
like hey man big fans of the show i was
watching last night with my you know
husband and my kids but i'm a puritan
and and they were like i just you know
when you guys start swearing a lot we
like don't want our kids to hear that
kind of language and then we're like all
right
i understand we we we want to we want to
give proper values and manners to
children and we can do this show and we
can be
something like
that that people can listen to sometimes
because we do get spicy stories when
their kids are around i respect that i
do and so we're like trying not to swear
if you swear it happens you know we're
not going to cry about it i had a couple
of those emails too i remember calling
bill gates uh a special name i can't
name here
and then i get an email saying that uh
one of the viewers toddlers was just
repeating it
like thanks uh
here's my favorite he's like i'm not
gonna and then people were like i'm not
just gonna watch your show i can't watch
your show because of this so i
understand that that's why
family-friendly show on my show as well
yeah as long as we're getting the ideas
across and we're able to talk about
important subjects i've got no problem
with okay we won't swear my favorite was
when we were talking about
a group of people that are all in a big
circle together yes and they're all
patting each other on the back oh yes
complimenting each other for being jerks
and it was a circle of jerks yes of
course and we call it something else
more adult and then i got a couple
emails and they were one of them was
like hey man big fan uh i just had to
spend you know the past 15 minutes after
your show explaining to my kid what that
meant
just wanted to let you know that like
when we're in the car and i'm taking my
kids somewhere and we put the show on
and i'm like
we'll say a circle of jerks all patting
each other on the back instead of you
know the other way
yes when it comes to comedy though you
can't let your audience decide how you
run your show so this isn't a comedy
show if it was
you know take the censorship off and
that i agree with too like when it comes
to comedy someone could be like hey man
you can't say that around me because i
got kids like it's a comedy show you
shouldn't bring your kids yeah this is
where we get like unless we're doing
children's comedy like why did why did
the chicken cross the road
funny joke
i wouldn't watch that on youtube anyway
it'd be creepy and probably against you
know whatever that new law is that coppa
whatever the heck it was oh yeah yeah
the anti-kids thing yeah that everybody
freaked out about i want to talk about
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time